if a guy's traveling he's probably
making six figures and you're asking for
a man that's making six figures
for me to ask what do you bring to a guy
that makes six figures you won't even
live with him listen so what you're
gonna give him children listen without
having to be very but you're 30 31.
listen so maybe one I'll tell you my
sister yeah just because your father is
a millionaire and everybody knows it
doesn't mean that I don't come from
somewhere where I actually have access
to these Elite men if I'm ready to get
there that's the thing I am not I am not
a typical Western girl and I'm not a
typical immigrant if I'm demanding for a
man to be on a certain level it's not
because I'm so deluded that I'm down
here and I'm not going to be able to
reach a man on that level that's the
thing I work very hard on myself to
ensure that I am going to be the person
can have that sort of man